un panneau et une flèche pour indiquer
la direction celle de l'Assemblée
nationale quelques heures seulement
après sa victoire dans les Yvelines
Aurore berger parmi les premières à
découvrir sous le soleil le Palais
Bourbon une prise de repère qui a 30 ans
à peine en rappelle d'autres alors il y
a pas les parents qui m'accompagnent
donc ça va j'ai quand même grandi depuis
l'école mais c'est beaucoup d'émotion
c'est très solennel moi je suis déjà
entré à l'Assemblée nationale mais ça
n'a rien à voir d'entrer pour la
première fois en tant que député de la
nation pose devant les photographes et
interview à la chaîne après les jardins
des quatre colonnes la nouvelle députée
dispose désormais d'une mallette avec
écharpe et règlements intérieur voilà
vous allez devoir le lire ah bah r Oui
surtout et le respecter et le respecter
parce que c'est pas toujours le cas et
puis dernière étape de la visite
l'hémicycle je pense que c'est important
aussi de s'imprégner de la solennité des
lieux pour comprendre ce qu'on attend de
nous pour comprendre la gravité du
moment la responsabilité qui doit être
la nôtre donc voilà c'était c'est
symbolique mais c'est aussi très
important pour bien intégrer le travail
que l'on va faire à partir d'aujourd'hui
en tout ils sont 400 à découvrir
l'Assemblée nationale cette semaine
parmi eux Nadia e et Béatrice Piron de
la République en marche député de la 11e
et 3e circonscription des Yvelines pour
les élus de la majorité présidentielle
l'apprentissage se poursuivra ce weekend
avec un séminaire de travail prévu à
Paris